Lindsey Graham is with us least he would
have brought on size cream if he had
such a freezer
she's been vicious all day okay she's
not at work she's she's blaming
President Trump for everything she was
telling people February 24 come to
Chinatown dummy that was a dumb idea
she was impeaching Trump when Trump put
the travel ban in effect and now she's
holding the money as hostage again yeah
I think she's been incredibly small at a
time when the country needs big
leadership you remember she held the
articles of impeachment from December
the 18th of January to the 15th trying
to get Mitch McConnell to bend to her
will to conduct a trial that she wanted
in the Senate she held phase three
hostage get money for the Kennedys
senator Kenny sinner and other stuff now
she's trying to hold the Small Business
Administration loan program that's
working hostage she's been a hostage
taker rather than a problem solver and
the one thing I want to say about
President Trump the guy that I've got to
know in the last three years listens and
he leads
he listens to dr. pouchy and dr. Burks
and he's come up with a phased opening
of the country he listens he leads and
Nancy Pelosi
undermines stories perhaps you've been
far have you been following Brett bears
reporting about how yes the the patient
zero is a guy that got infected with
corona from a bat he worked in that
Wuhan laboratory now I had seen all the
conspiracy theories that it was
manufactured there
okay this report doesn't say that but
apparently China banned travel in and
out of Wuhan private province according
to Brett but they let people from Wuhan
travel internationally and infect the
rest of the world and this is the result
now that would mean to me that they
knowingly consciously assuming all this
is true as reported that they've
protected themselves and screwed the
rest of us with the help of the w-h-o
that lied to us
yeah all the evidence indicates that
they lock their country down to protect
their people and they did not tell the
world about the true state of play
inside of China Iran is the larger state
sponsor of terrorism China is the
largest state sponsor of pandemics this
is the third 1/4 pandemic that came out
of China this may have happened the
infection may have happened in a lab but
the evidence seems to suggest it was
spread at these wet markets what do we
do to Iran who's a bad actor we
sanctioned Iran what should we do to the
largest state sponsor of pandemics on
the globe which is sanctioned China to
get them to change it senator
senator Cruz has a bill to do that they
need to pay for this because that means
that they knew who Homme was so
dangerous you couldn't travel in or out
within China but that would mean they
have blood on my hands because if it was
if they didn't tell the rest of the
world well and what they were doing with
Wuhan but they let Luhan you know people
travel everywhere else they didn't give
a flying rip about what they were doing
or the rest of the world they knew it
was bad and they let it happen if it
were not for the irresponsibility of the
Chinese Communist Party there would be
no pandemic in the world Americans would
be alive today and 22 million people
would be at work
China is responsible it's time to hold
them responsible they're the largest
state sponsor of pandemics in the entire
globe and they need to pay a price yeah
maybe we're not gonna pay back the debt
they're holding let's start there they
pay for this they pay for all of this
all right senator thank you